giants are signing running back devante
freeman to fill the void created by the
season-ending injury to running back
saquon barkley freeman i'm told gets up
to three million dollars this year up to
means the base level is a lot lower he's
going to have to perform to get it but
you know what this is the thing that i
always say when an adrian peterson gets
dumped onto the market late and has this
compulsion to go find another job right
now yeah for running backs there's value
in waiting because i guarantee you if
adrian peterson hadn't signed with the
lions he'd have gotten a pretty good
deal to sign with the giants once saquon
barkley's out for the year chris well
yeah yes he he would have he certainly
could have dangled their feet by the
fire a little bit more and probably
squeezed some more money out of them
there's no doubt
uh but i guess he felt like there was a
need to go there in detroit there was
and they want to run the football and
again maybe the giants wouldn't have
been a place where he would have looked
at anyways because this offensive line
is not good they can't open up any holes
for saquon barkley and i don't expect
them to be opening up holes anytime soon
for devonta freeman or anybody else so
devonta freeman we'll we'll see what he
has you know left on his tires as well
he's been a guy that you know was
visited what do you think mike three
four different teams here this offseason
seattle jacksonville are the two that i
can remember right and jackson okay and
then you know we had the we heard the
conversations that maybe he was asking
for too much money uh enduring free
agency to go somewhere you know he's a
smaller type running back who runs like
he's ezekiel elliott he's been beat up
but the giants have a real need and they
don't really have again
like a guy that i think is a proven
commodity that you can trust they got
wayne gallman okay he's still young and
he hasn't done anything dion lewis all
right he's a third down tight back so
devonta freeman's kind of that first and
second type bat down back that can run
the football and pick up blitzes and has
been around the block a few times 656
rushing yards last year in 14 games it's
been several years since devante francis
last thousand yard game a season rather
thousand yard game would be significant
thousand yard season it's been several
uh years and you know he's a guy who
who flashed potential early in his
career and and created the allure of a
potential workhorse tailback short list
top in the nfl and never quite punched
through i mean let's face it he never
quite punched through completely part of
it is kevin coleman was there as well
right but it but but look he he gets his
chance now he waited and waited and this
was his best opportunity with the
season-ending injury to saquon barkley
so we'll see what he can do the giants
clearly have a need and there may be a
great opportunity there because if the
defense is now say we're going to drop
extra guys into coverage and force danny
dimes to to beat us there may be some
running lanes for de ante france yeah
there might be it's going to be about
you know you know like you said it's
it's it's been a physical career and he
has seemed to have fizzled out a little
bit unfortunately i mean it really is
because he was a really good player this
is what stinks about the nfl he is
literally the poster child for like
running back where you go man okay first
few years pretty good believe he got a
second deal right as soon as he got that
second deal you were like whoa i think
he might be done i mean maybe you got
one real good year out of him out of
that second deal but then the body just
fell to crap
and you know here he is yeah not that
long after just going to the super bowl
and being one of the better running
backs in the game to now you're going
damn we're four years later and he he
can barely find a team to get on it's
just the sad story of the running back
and uh hey it's good for him that he
found a home they need him you're right
it's not going to be easy there though
the giants offensively are challenged as
we know right now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports